how do y'all know each other cousins I
knew it was customers and not just
because they're Indian I don't think all
Indians hanging out together cousins but
none of them hanging out together made
sense any other way
then these two should be sitting next to
each other in any capacity look how look
how [__] adorable this kid is
it I [__] knew it man I knew I could
tell by his [__] glasses this guy
pretended to be smarter than he is
software engineer it all made perfect
sense what about you what do you do
you're a data analyst why you look like
this
you got on a pearl necklace you got a
[__] Diamond chain pendant you look
at data I'm
not it sounds like I'm mad I just it
doesn't add up to me
as a data analyst you make a lot what do
you think a lot is because that chain
not that big
[Laughter]
and it's a Nautica sweater which also
doesn't add up
spending thousands of dollars on jewelry
getting his sweaters at Burlington Coat
Factory that's the dad I'd like you to
analyze
how does this make sense you have a door
to your job in him somehow
I Know This Much best father
your daddy ain't [__] probably
[Applause]
I'm nice at this no father gotta let his
[__] kid leave the house like this
that dumbass haircut is suddenly the
house with a pearl necklace unless he
gave us the only way I will respect you
if you wear a pearl necklace you suck a
lot of dick well don't give me no
mediocre sucks either you're gonna be
out there sucking away Hoover vacuum
auric XL I knew you ain't had no daddy
that [__] made perfect sense
kid yeah
I'm not a Daddy who left him I'm taking
him in
I'm basically Russell Wilson up here at
the end of the day
what's up with the rest of you guys what
do y'all do
marketing
what what about you what uh you have a
rap album you want me to this download
on Spotify
HR nothing about you says appropriate
[Applause]
you look like the most sexually
harassing [__] this table if I
had to guess unbelievable dude how are
you HR [__] boy haircut [__] boy beard
[__] boy heck y'all to go out in a
[__] Lacosta women together I think I
don't trust any company you work for
dude I don't trust it at all what is it
steer what is steer
son you're a drug dealer
[Music]